salut dans quelques secondes vous allez
voir une vidéo qui va parler de
mathématiques comme ça si vous voulez
fuir c'est maintenant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va se faire une petite
astuce mathématiques des familles
ça fait plaisir ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ça va être à la fois une
astuce de maths
oui mais aussi une manière de bluffer
les gens si vous voulez c'est à vous
d'en faire ce que vous voulez au final
puisque dans quelques minutes vous serez
capable d'extraire une racine cubique de
tête générés
vous allez demander à quelqu'un de
choisir un nombre à deux chiffres dans
sa tête il choisit un nombre à deux
chiffres avec une calculatrice ou avec
son téléphone y multiplie ce chiffre par
lui-même une fois une seconde fois ainsi
la le cube de son chiffre de départ
il vous donne le cube et vous en
quelques secondes à peine vous êtes
capable de retrouver le chiffre original
puisque vous savez extraire une racine
cubique le dire qui ne s'est pas
extraire une racine cubique
le pire c'est que c'est simple à faire
c'est encore plus simple que pour les
quarts et on avait déjà fait une vidéo
sur extraire un quart et mentalement le
cube c'est beaucoup plus simple vous
avez simplement dit chose à retenir
alors évidemment vous pouvez les écrire
quelque part les noter vous faire une
antisèche mais je vous recommande de les
apprendre une bonne fois pour toutes on
a vu assez de technique de mémoire cette
année ou de visualisation pour retenir
ça ce que vous devez retenir et je me
mets sur le côté pour vous notez en même
temps c'est que le cube de 0 c zéro le
cube de 1 c1 l'occupent deux de ses huit
l'occupent de 3 c 27 occupe de 4 c 64
le cube de 5,625 l'occupent 2,6 et 216
le cube de cette c343 le cube de 8 ses
512 et le cube de 9 729
une fois que vous savez ça vous savez
extraire une racine cubique donc la
personne à qui vous avez demandé de
penser un nombre à deux chiffres et
qu'il la multiplier deux fois par son
propre chiffre
en clair qui a fait le cube de ce
chiffre vous donne un résultat serré des
résultats à cinq ou six chiffres
prenons par exemple 30 9304 39 1304 ces
cinq chiffres à chaque fois vous allez
séparé en deux pour avoir de l'eau les
trois derniers et les deux ou trois
premiers d'abord on s'intéresse aux deux
ou trois premiers ici c'est 39 ce sont
les deux premiers mais dans ma tête
c'est 0,39 les trois premiers je suis
pas sûr d'être toujours clair mais je
suis sûr que vous comprenez vous
cherchez dans votre tableau que vous
avez écrit ou appris ou est-ce que
sincère votre résultat et moi 39 je sais
que c'est entre 27 et 64 donc le premier
chiffre de la racine cubique sera soit
1,3 soit 1,4 puisque dont 39 est situé
entre 27 et 64 et vous prenez le plus
petit des deux puisque l'autre il
dépasserait donc je sais que ça commence
par un trois et pour le chiffre des
unités savez d'en voir plus simple de le
trouver vous prenez les trois derniers
donc ici 300 cartes et même encore plus
simple vous prenez juste l'unité de ses
trois derniers donc ici le 4 et vous
cherchez dans le tableau calcul finit
par quatre il y en a pas deux qui
finissent par la même chose sur les dix
est le seul qui finit par quatre c'est
celui de 4,64 donc je sais que l'unité
sera 4 donc leur
zulte ac34 la racine cubique de 39 1304
ses 34 un peu comme l'âge que je vais
avoir dans quelques jours on ne se moque
pas de mon âge je vous rappelle la
méthode très rapide vous demander à
quelqu'un de penser un nombre à deux
chiffres de faire le cube de ce nombre
est de vous le donnez vous prenez vous
les deux ou trois premiers vous cherchez
dans votre tableau où est-ce qui
s'insère entre deux résultats un
prochain dessous un proche au dessus et
vous prenez le plus petit des deux
pourra voir le chiffre des dizaines pour
celui des unités vous prenez l'unité du
cube convient de vous donner et vous
cherchez dans votre tableau youtube qui
finit par cette même unité l'a essayé de
le faire vous allez voir je voulais dit
c'est encore plus simple que d'extraire
une racine carrée si vous n'êtes pas
super chaud pour la prendre dès
aujourd'hui par coeur notez le au moins
dans votre téléphone dans note dans
quelque chose vous pourrez le faire avec
ça la pluie et ça va vous entraîner à le
faire de temps en temps merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
a plu
si c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de laisser
un pouce en l'air c'est très important
et n'oubliez pas également que vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne en
cliquant ici
ou alors par ici du coup puisque le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
prendre un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
et ouais donc rendez vous demain à 17h
ciao
là
et